station casinos celebrating the grand
opening today of two new medical
facilities for its team members
kate houston is live this afternoon from
red rock casino on the west side of town
with what's being offered kate
yes we're inside the medical center here
at red rock casino where any station
casino member
can come for assistance and while this
wasn't built as a result of the pandemic
station casino says they're happy to
help their team members during a year
where health care
is so important now this morning team
members from various areas of the casino
as well as healthcare professionals were
on hand to cut the red ribbon
and welcome everyone inside the new
medical centers at red rock and sunset
station
will offer free medical visits lab
testing generic prescriptions
and other health services i spoke to
station casino ceo bob finch
who says this process started two years
ago when they wanted to reignite their
focus on family
he says little did they know just how
important that focus would be this year
we kind of built the whole program
around what they needed and not just for
them we thought it was very important
for us to make sure we take care of
their family members because if you can
worry about your family at home and you
know that your
your significant other and your children
are taken care of it just makes
everything more easy
coo bob finch says they'd like to
continue to expand these medical
facilities to other properties
another medical facility was planned at
texas station but since they haven't
opened that property yet they haven't
built it
moving forward finch says that the
medical services offered inside of these
facilities
are really just the beginning he'd like
to add eye care
and dental care as well reporting from
the new medical center in red rock
casino kate houston 8 news